okay
right like to
welcome everybody to this infrastructure
meeting
7th of september
2021
uh
it's going to be an interesting day
today what we're going to do first is
we're going to do a couple of
small lighting items on the agenda and
then we're going to adjourn the meeting
and then pass over to his worship to
open the
extraordinary
council meeting
so
to start to start this meeting
apologies
there are none that i'm aware of
so that moves on to
i'm working up an old-fashioned paper
here
there's no public forum and the first
item is to receive the minutes
of the infrastructure services meeting
held on the 3rd of august
2021.
can i have someone move that please i'll
move those councillor
thank you that was council lewis
seconded
councillor soper i'll put that all those
in favor
aye
thank you again
that is carried
now we're going to move on to
item six which is the explanation of
water supply gratings
as applied to invercargill and bluff
and who is speaking to that
us alistair welcome to the meeting
allison
and mute thank you i've unlocked
it's all yours
uh yes well this report's just in um
response to
question that was raised at the last
infrastructure meeting i think
to do with um the key performance
indicator not being met obtaining a
a a rating for the township of bluff
the short answer is that the ministry of
the health are no longer
following along the exercise of water
supply grading so we couldn't
be regulated instead they are
concentrating on a concept
which is called a water safety plan
which is a risk-based approach
rather than
sort of the yen based
sampling
approach that was done
historically
in the water safety plans you have to be
able to demonstrate what your risks are
how you're managing and monitoring
against those risks
and the water safety plan is audited
annually by the
ministry of house representative
the drinking water assessors
so
invercargill has a current water safety
plan
it first of all had to be meet certain
standards it did and was passed by the
ministry of health and it has had
successful audits every year since then
so
[Music]
that point i should say that
even under the old system the water
supply grading we feel that
if we were
subject to the
rules and regulations that
are applied for
rating
bluff would have achieved an a grading
the grading we were aimed for
this council has over a long period of
time since 2009
committed to addressing a lot of the
shortcomings of the water supply system
down in bluff
we had problems with high leakage
poor pressure control fluctuating
pressure
and poor
fire fighting
plus a whole lot of other little issues
as well so progressively through the
years we've worked through those really
reconfiguring the whole of the water
distribution system down at bluff
as i said earlier we believe that if the
old system of wood supply grading was in
place we would have achieved an a
for the water down at bluff
so at this point i'm open for
any further questions by way of
explanation if anybody wishes to pose
them
thank you alistair right i'm going to
open up two questions
any questions for alistair regarding
this
no i think aleister that's that's well
done
that solves that mystery
right
okay thank you uh the uh
hey the recommendation is that this
report be received so um can i have
someone move that please oh that way
uh we had uh council abbott moved that
and i saw councillor skelt seconding
that i'll put the motion all those in
favor
that is carried
right i see um bruce robertson has now
arrived
i have thank you
okay right so
uh i
would like to move that we adjourn the
infrastructure meeting
can i have someone second that please
you're just adjourning
right
okay it's adjourned
we're here darren i wasn't trying to
permanently on that uh standing orders
is a bit vague on that
so
i will pass over to his worship
and uh councillor partner can i just
confirm with comms that they don't need
to stop this live stream to start
council
okay comms are you there
uh yes i've got a message on chat now
it's just comes through they'll edit the
videos later so we can go straight on
okay thank you
sorry your worship that's back to you
now
yeah
right all right yep
um
again welcome the um emergency council
meeting
even for september
2021
uh
good afternoon councillors and everyone
watching on zoom
once again i'm limited by one screen
and have a limited view of the
participants
in order to make the meeting more
seamless i would ask that someone
with more access to technology
here the meeting
the council of pottinger has taken steps
to ensure
he can share the infrastructure
meeting
it has two large screens
i'd like to move the council of foreign
to chair today's meeting
saying
uh secondary
put it to the vote all i'm saying to say
all right
okay
hand over to you counselor
thank you your worship yes it's
certainly an advantage uh
having the screens and and my wife alice
has finally donated her office to me so
thank you
um
right i'd like to welcome richard
thompson
you know richard
and also bruce robertson good day bruce
thank you
and uh right we're going to um
actually
need someone to move that we accept this
late item
i'd like to say move councillor potter
thank you secondary
yeah
thank you
was that councilor abbott uh-huh
okay um those in favor
hi hi
yes that is carried right
start up my ipad
right we have the
six month review findings and next steps
and i'm going to pass over to its author
richard
flora is yours
uh thank you councillor pottinger um
look i i would like to make a few
comments i think to preface
this
i have
endeavoured since
my original report to
remain as invisible as possible
but i think there are some comments that
i i think need to be made and that i
would like to make in introducing
the report um
some of them are covered in the report
but there will be people watching this
live stream who have not read it and i
think it's important that some of them
are acknowledged in public
the original report on council was a
very difficult one to write
and two days into it i would have
cheerfully run for the hills as i
discovered what i got myself into
nevertheless i took a view that unless i
was absolutely honest to what i found
and the conclusions that led me to i
would be doing a disservice
most of it was very difficult to write
and i was always conscious of the impact
that my findings would have on people
and i say that because it's equally
important to understand that i've taken
the same approach in the writing of the
six months review
council both governance and management
alike could have dismissed my very
strong criticism of what i found last
term
and it's important therefore that i
reinforce the very significant changes
that i have found six months on
[Music]
it's inevitable but unfair that much of
the media focus goes on his worship
now i can't resile from the fact that
he's a key player in these reports and
he was a major focus of my original
report
but it would be unfortunate and i
believe unfair if the media continued
that focus at the expense of the very
real change that has occurred in this
council since my original report
six months ago there was very real
concern from the department of internal
affairs as to whether this council could
deliver on its obligations to the rate
payers of invercargill
that was reflected in concerns around
the vacuum of leadership
powerful personalities sometimes at war
with each other a failure to
differentiate between governance and
management by some councillors and some
management behaviors also that needed
attention to if that was to be fixed
and of most immediate concern was
whether the council could deliver
appropriately on a long-term plan for
the city
what i found six months later is a
council governance and management who've
taken my very strong criticisms on board
and largely dealt to them
senior councillors have stepped up to
work cooperatively in the likes of
chairs roles the deputy mayor has
addressed ways of operating that i was
very critical of and significantly
helped fill a leadership vacuum
a largely new senior management
structure has addressed really well my
challenge to identify better the
information that counsellors needed to
make good decisions and facilitated
strong workshops to ensure that that was
well understood
and the long-term plan was seen by
almost all involved as a successful
process
and many councillors talk to me about
the sense of engagement they felt around
it and external parties have reinforced
that view back to me
it's not a perfect process show me a
council that is
it remains at risk because of the
peculiar circumstances that surround
aspects of it
but it's important that the people of
invercargill know and understand that
this is not the same council it was six
months ago
that this is far more for example than
about the mayor at the end of the day
the mayor's just one part of a council
team
important yes but one vote amongst 13
and if the focus were to remain on him
at the expense of the very real
improvement
then it will it will ignore i think what
this council has shown it can achieve
and frankly if that were to be the case
then the media should line up too for
the issue of the blame
i think i should also comment briefly on
the timeline of my report
whilst i completed interviews in july
and wrote the bulk of the report in the
first week of august
i held off completing it till the
separate survey data was available
during that period and the subsequent
delay
in in meeting that covert caused there
were a number of primarily media stories
that either themselves or the situations
that led to them meant i needed to
reflect on whether my report was still
accurate
you will see if you read it that i've
continued to address matters that have
arisen through august and the report
went through several iterations as a
result
and the fundamental question i had to
ask was whether any of those matters
changed any of my key conclusions
i i came to a view that they didn't but
i have reflected that some risks have
possibly been escalated as a result
as i say in the report the council is a
work in progress but i would sincerely
wish that the people of invercargill
recognise the very real progress made
and my view that the whole of council as
it's currently operating is meeting the
fundamental requirements that its rate
players should expect of it
thank you richard that um
right i'm bruce
would you like to say something now
look i would thank you very much for
running and uh greetings to the whole
council
um
look the the my role is to reflect that
on top of richard's paper
uh the risk and assurance committee met
yesterday um to consider what was a
suitable response to
um
to richard's report
and
so i bring to you what is in effect the
recommendation of my committee what i
would like to reflect of course is the
majority i think all of you will know
uh that that committee was
an invitation to all councillors to join
the risk and assurance committee members
so that we would have a chance
to firstly meet with richard
and secondly to work through what is a
substantive paper in terms or a
substantial paper in terms of the
response
to to richard's report and so the paper
i bring to you and i'm very grateful to
claire and jane for for getting me to
this point um is
a set of recommendations
[Music]
that i would ask council to consider
positively
into adopt
as our steps forward
in response to these important findings
that richard has made
just to reflect a wee bit on process
richard's report
um
was always
well and long signaled
we realized when we first started the
working on working together program in
response to his original report
that at the six-month point we would
want some sense of evaluation
and originally
we were going to ask the eas
uh jeff and lindsay to undertake that
review
but as events transpired
we all agreed that it would be useful to
wrap that up in this review
uh performed by richard
and it's been worth the wait
so we're very grateful um uh to richard
for his work
and indeed the fact that he's confident
to publicly
um put his findings uh in front of us
which is that we were prepared as a
council to look in the face of
i think what you already said this
afternoon richard is some somewhat stern
criticism
and that we have made substantial gains
and i would like to also uh
compliment you richard that you're
prepared to say to the rate payer that
actually they should have confidence in
the council i'd like to go one step
further
and recognize this started because we
had a ministerial letter
and actually this should also enable the
minister to have confidence
in invercargill city and the gains that
it's made
however
yesterday at the committee we also
recognised
that actually as richard has said we're
not perfect and there are still risks
so
the recommendations
um uh clearly
look to build on
the findings and indeed the
recommendations in richard's report
i guess the key principle of the
recommendations the committee considered
yesterday and adopted
are ones of embedding
the gains we have made
it's asking councillors to consider
specifically
how we embed the gains made through
matters like the charter and actually
how we ensure we have behaviour
that is appropriate
and has already been displayed for the
last six months
because i would like to recommend
councillors in looking at this report
and our recommendations
you're laying the foundation not just
for the rest
of the trienium
but indeed for the new council
come post october next year
so rangi i think
that's important to note there is one
thing that that i think is useful to
also note from our deliberations
yesterday
the members will recognize these
recommendations fairly quickly for your
involvement with my committee yesterday
but i would also want to reflect that a
substantial part of our debate was
around
recommendation 7
and i appreciate the very
open and strong debate we had around
recommendation seven and that has been
updated um uh in the way that we we
passed and moved and uh so for those of
you looking at this paper that is the
key change from yesterday so rangi with
that um i would i would like to commend
this report which has come from the risk
and assurance committee to hall of
council
and i would encourage you to engage with
it and indeed to adopt the
modified approach which is uh laid out
in its uh contents um thanks ring and
i'll leave it to you
thank you bruce for that um
look we've got the 11 recommendations
there
but obviously
i'm going to open this for debate so the
two things are
the to debate about the recommendations
which are put forward if there is
further discussion and also
on richard's report so i am going to
open the floor
for discussion
oh i'll let a wonderful thing
no no i haven't moved it yet i'm just no
no sorry your worship
i'm just open opening the floor for
discussion
rebecca thanks it looks like i'm going
to be going first
i just wanted to extend my thanks to
richard for
writing a report that i think accurately
reflects the situation that the council
is currently in
um and that's a situation of being on a
journey
i'd also like to acknowledge all of the
effort that all of the councillors have
made
to
to be part of that journey
and
to work towards the greater good
i'd also note that i am purposely saying
councillors in that comment
i think we're also really lucky that we
have had the faith of the staff to work
with us on this process
um they've worked really hard alongside
us
and have had faith that we have
that we as councillors as governance
we're going to
make a difference here and i'm sure that
that's
all because of the leadership of clear
i think it's also really important to
comment
on the comments made in the report about
nobby
or councillor clark i don't always agree
with his position um or the way he does
things but certainly um i'm more than
willing to acknowledge the effort that
he has made and the work that he has
done um in the last six months which i
think has played a really important role
in helping make sure that this council
is in the positive position that it's in
now
i'd also like to make a comment about
one portion of the report where it talks
about uh the deputy mayor
um challenging
the mayor on occasion uh when he's made
inaccurate statements especially with
regard to the staff
and i think it's really important to me
to note that in the eight years that
i've been on council
there's been little or no accountability
for people's bad behavior towards each
other on this council and i think one of
the benefits of this whole process for
council is that we're now in a position
where we are confident that holding each
other to account for our bad behavior or
comments
um
is something that we are willing to do
and i'm really glad to see that that's
happening
i'd look like to reflect on richard's
comments that he's just made around his
hope for the public and the media that
they
focus on the good progress that we have
made
and that
we all continue on this journey
following the recommendations that we
have in this report i'd just like to
acknowledge or to note that yesterday's
recommendation 7 is today's
recommendation six um and that's about
the media protocols etc
and so
if uh if you're happy for me to move
those recommendations i'm more than
happy to do that
i think we're on a great journey and i'm
looking forward to the next uh six
months to see where we get to
thanks
i'm happy to thicken that moving of the
recommendations mr chair
thank you rebecca thank you
leslie we have a mover in the secondary
um before i put the motion though i will
uh now move to cancel ludlow you were
next on the list
thanks cheer um
without repeating anything that
councillor amundsen said and and i
wholeheartedly agree with each of the
points that she raised i think one of
the other areas in which um council has
managed to develop since mr thompson's
first report is is gaining confidence in
how we disagree
there was a point where we had i've i
felt become
hesitant to disagree with each other for
the way that it might be played out in
the media now we can all have
12 or 13 different opinions but it's
about understanding that
not everyone's going to agree with you
and and it's their opinion that you're
not agreeing with it's not the person
that you're disagreeing with and
whilst there are times that we want to
go out
and and present united front you know
here's a great example with with what
we're doing today
um if if somebody respectfully wants to
take a different position that's that's
fine we should have comfort in in doing
that so that the public understand that
we um we do thrash things out and and i
think we've grown tremendously in that
area over the past couple of months
thank you
thank you council ludlow
further discussion
from councils
yes you wish
yes
thank you to all those involved in using
this document uh as i'm sure will be the
guide for the future
however
i believe that it contains delegations
which are presented as facts
for the record
i would say
following
the report
mentions a
mural sideshow
proven by the mayor
if mr thompson had undertaken more
research of media radical articles
he would notice i'm constantly in a
position of having
to defend myself from attacks
by the deputies
they are not
instigated always by me
the report makes no mention of my latest
report or anything the council has
specifically done to address statistics
the report touches lightly on the
serious allegations of bullying and
downplays the serious issue of email
interception
is that you finished your worship is
that all
thank you for that
um
further comments
leslie
thanks mr chair i'm also not going to
repeat what um councillor munson very
well said and councillor ludlow said
but i do want to reflect on
the fact that i believe this council has
made made huge strides
um from from where we are when mr
thompson was called in and when we
received the department of internal
affairs letter
and i do want to reflect that i believe
we have reached the point there's a very
famous saying of the duke of wellington
in relation to
to battle and organization where he says
there comes a point where you tie a knot
and go onwards
i think this report from mr thompson and
thank you very much for it reflects the
fact that council has done more than
thai and not
councillors have looked at behaviours
councillors have acted as adults
have acknowledged that there were some
things that could be improved that there
were some ways in which we could work
better together
that there were some need
to reflect on relationships with staff
and make sure that those were on the
track they should be i think there have
been great strides made that has been
more than tying a knot it has given us
the basis to say
that we have reached a point where we
can
honestly say to our community
this council has
got to the point where you can have full
confidence
that we will go on to be a good council
on that basis i'm very happy to
second these recommendations i believe
that we do have a very solid basis on
which to progress
to fulfill what we are asked to deliver
to
our ratepayers and residents as to
responsible governance
and i am personally very happy to be a
member of this council who has taken the
adult approach
of reflecting on ourselves
and finding a way for us all to move
forward
i'm sorry if the mayor is still not
prepared
to join in that very adult approach
but i believe that we are a council who
can continue to be proud of the way we
are moving forward thank you
thank you councillor sopa
so
i would like to make a comment or two oh
yes sorry uh councillor abbott i
no no visuals yes no no no visual's not
worth looking at today
i would just uh like to just touch on
one of two points and i hope that i'm
being fair-minded i like to be
fair-minded and probably in this
instance i'm going to speak longer than
i do in any other council meeting it's a
sorrowful time for me to actually see
what's happened play out in the press
the as is who said i said the counter
claims and claims etc
and
one of the points i wish to address and
have addressed it already with the mayor
when he confirmed in the paper on
several times that he had no support
from councillors or anybody else that in
fact it was not true
and he is aware as i am aware that we
talked to we discussed i gave opinions
and profit advice
whether he took it or not um is his
prerogative
fortunately unfortunately sometimes he
didn't take it but as i say that's his
prerogative um i just find to see a
friend a colleague and an often
adversary in past decades um scrutinized
in the paper criticized in the subject
of media trial
not all from the other side but this
part as well
was a game plan that i would never take
part in and i don't believe the game
plan is appropriate to true southlanders
and i will also go further and say there
was some care and i acknowledged the
care and concerns that were made evident
to me by eas some councillors inclusive
of the ce and i referred to the fact
that uh
when they recognized and tim himself
recognized that he didn't have the
skills to run a meeting with technology
i was approached and suggested can you
tell turmoil asked him would he be
comfortable with somebody else cheering
that meeting and i was happy to be the
messenger on that
um the thompson review as you have all
said states categorically that we've
moved forward progressed and performed
and i believe that there has been a
sense of working together for the public
good and i think and acknowledge the
considerable achievements
the democratic process has been to the
fore
and democracy rules
even though we had a no vote in the ltp
from lobby that's a bit of humor um so i
agree to that most part to the latest
review but i just want to touch on
what i consider
bullying i considered it bullying and i
saw that actually in the um structure of
the report from mr thompson but i've
come across another word that i'd like
to use now we call that unconscious
bullying and that has been deployed by
some even by me to tim
and i apologize for that
and i just want to give you a couple of
examples if you consider this at the
cheers meeting and i just want to
elaborate on
three words vote of no confidence i
think that might be four words vote of
no confidence that was said just prior
to a meeting that the mayor was about to
cheer
now we all saw the impact of that he was
wondering whether it was going to be
brought up at that meeting he was
nervous and he didn't know when it was
going to arise
and we all witnessed a very sorrowful
meeting let's be faint
then it was denied that the
statement had been made then only to be
corrected again in a further press
statement saying oh yes it was made but
it said it might happen sometime in the
future
was that fear
not in my example not in my example
another example that i want to quote was
the mere vacate the chair when it was
introduced to council the problem about
his driving licence it was suggested the
chair should be a councillor endorsed by
another chairman deputy chair and my
response then was it was orchestrated by
the cheers committee and it was a
surprise tactic and lacked the very
principle of the recently signed charter
councillor cypher venomously denied it
was orchestrated or designed
how she had that knowledge not being
part of the chairman's committee rather
astounded me
interestingly as i left council that day
one of the eas approached me and told me
my assumption was quite right
so
in my words the operative words in my
opinion in page 44 of mr thompson's
report in the executive version
page 21 could all contribute to an
impression of bullying and further could
appear like kicking someone when they
are down
followed by his very astute observation
council might like to reflect on that
and that is the operative word reflect
indeed all of us inclusive of the mayor
need to reflect
i have concerns as i said that has been
played out in the press
being played out whereas in my opinion
the right action would have been us as
adults to have an informal meeting of
elected representatives only and give
all parties the right to hear their
views come to a compromise find the way
forward and move on
that used to be the southland way the
way i and many others adopted in times
of conflict
these actions i said that they said
claims and counter claims negate the
positive achievements i believe and the
works the council have done and it just
becomes a feeding frenzy for some of the
public
the majority of the public just want us
to see a progressive working together
united council along with healthy debate
working in the interests of the
electorate we're just over a year in
this trideum i believe we are a working
council lemire has only one vote
and if tim wants to continue and talk
and go about
his
personal agendas or make comment in the
press which we do not like we just have
to remember that there are 12 of us that
vote
and uh the potential for a six six vote
i believe
in this particular instant would be rare
enough harmony around the table and i
can't envisage a um
a special vote from the mayor being used
so
let's continue on
let's be a formative council let's work
for the electorate and
let the people decide the mandate
thirteen months from now
thank you
thank you council forever um
i don't see anyone else with a hand up
uh
yes counselor ken
thank you uh chairman just going on from
what councillor abbott had to say
uh
on that day in question when mayor tim
entered the council chamber that was on
the 10th of august okay he cut a very
very lonely figure indeed
there was one of my saddest days on
council
and being around for a very very long
time
i would hate to see anything like that
again
it was obvious that his worship was
unwell
and what we've heard since about what
was playing on his mind that maybe there
was going to be a a comment or a vote of
no confidence
um
that was very very sad
and
i was a man of his ability over the
years he's done a brilliant job he's
been one of the team in recent times
as the reporter said he's gone his own
separate way
but i ask every one of you out there
well council of
has anyone ever taken a bit of time out
and
called around to see his worship
ask how he's getting on
not
not not comment not commenting about uh
council matters
just about his well-being
uh
i've heard one say yes
i'm another
look i know during
it was awkward to call around and see
him during uh shut down that covered
three weeks when we're out of commission
but just a simple phone call
just a simple phone call
i can't see anyone raising their hand
look he's our leader we're supposed to
be part of the team
yes in the report he has overstepped the
mark he's gone his own way
but he deserves more than what he's been
getting from us
yeah
the 12 of us that's all i've got to say
thank you
counselor kit
any other further
discussion
okay i might uh
say a couple of words now i wasn't going
to but
uh oh sorry counselor cricket are you
wanting to speak
counselor cricket
sorry you're muted all right i was
pointing at councillor lewis not that
you can see that on my screen that he
has his hand
where is council lewis
yes sorry council lewis you're at the
top left
where you go
thank you chair
i am
a bit put out that we've had this
personal
conversation when we've got
the the emotion on the table effectively
but i actually take slightly exception
to the fact
that
mayor term has been bullied by everybody
or even some i've not been present in
the occasions where he's been bullied or
perceived to be bullied in fact
me and tim and i had a pleasant
afternoon after the meeting that gore to
which i took him because he wasn't able
to drive of course
we spent two hours after that meeting
i kept him company
we had nice little coffees and and
cheese rolls and i enjoyed the meeting
we had someone was waiting for a
personal reason to catch a bus to get to
go through and there's a terrible day in
gore we sat there quietly we had a nice
conversation
keeping him company for two hours
because he had a list that he kept
referring to about what time the bus
went um i don't think it's a case of
bullying i think we have tried to guide
merton
we also had a lot of respect for his
workshop over the years and it is a sad
situation to see perhaps his memory may
be going a little bit i make no comment
about that i'm not a doctor
but
he hasn't been bullied consistently in
my mind i respect his worship very much
and his partner when i rang her to say
i've been looking after him for that
afternoon that two hours until his bus
effectively went and when in fact a
member of the public noted that we were
sitting there and she made the very
generous offer to
make sure that tim met the the bus
um so i i drove back to invercargill
because i had the life to have too but
his partner was very gracious and very
happy that we had a nice afternoon and i
respected that afternoon worship and i
enjoyed that conversation with those
conversations none of the conversations
around revolved around council or
computer abilities or anything that
nature it was a nice afternoon
not a bullying
afternoon and i didn't have to sit there
for two hours but i enjoyed it thank you
thank you cheer
right
okay um right back to a couple of words
that i might say
um
let's talk about the bullying that i
wasn't going to go to but since it's
been raised it can't be left
unchallenged
i was at the meeting the cheers meeting
prior to
the mayor cheering the so-called other
meeting and
the allegations of a vote of no
confidence
now
the the cheers meeting was cheered by
jeff grant
and it was cheered
in a very orderly manner no one spoke
unless they went through the chair
and there was debate about various
topics and obviously the email was one
of those debates
at no stage looking back on that meeting
was there any bullying
i just about
yeah i just about weeped when i heard
that in the media
the allegations of bullying now that's a
very strong allegation and genuinely
when you make allegations like that you
would provide evidence
and we haven't seen evidence
so
hopefully i've left that lie because
that is counselor
that's just
that's just the way the system works
there is a bit of mudslinging going on
no problem i'll just i'll just wear that
and move on but when
people start grabbing
the word bullying and using it twisting
it
then i take a
exception to that because
in my view
it has never occurred
and the allegation of the voter no
confidence that's quite funny
just before
that meeting
uh the reporter matt rosenberg rushed up
to me at my seat
and asked me about is there going to be
a vote or no confidence and i said what
what's this vote of no confidence no
no that's i don't know about that so
i'm not sure
where that ever came from so
look yeah i'm just going to say my 10
cents worth because i want this
whole debate balance and at the moment i
see it slightly unbalanced
so
i've seen my bit now i see no other
hands up
i am now we've had to move from the
secondary i'm now going to put the
motion all those in favor
aye
do you wish your
vote recorded your worship
yes please
okay now we noted
that is carrie thank you and uh
thank you to richard thompson
and thank you to bruce for being here
and
no for the business i now declare the
meeting place thank you all
thank you appreciate it thanks mr chair